the house select committee investigating
the capital riot wrapped its first
series of public hearings on thursday we
have far more evidence to share with the
american people and more to gather the
committee was formed in the wake of the
january 6 20
attack on the capitol
in order to find out what happened the
eight televised hearings aimed to make
the case that former president donald
trump was accountable for the attack and
that it was the result of a
multi-pronged conspiracy trump has said
he's done nothing wrong and has called
the committee a partisan witch-hunt
the journal scott patterson explains how
the committee has presented evidence
they say shows that trump failed to
intervene after setting the stage for
the riot promoted baseless accusations
of election fraud and led a pressure
campaign to overturn the 2020 election
the committee's latest primetime session
zeroed in on trump's activities inside
the white house during the 187 minutes
after he gave his speech at the ellipse
on january 6.
according to live and recorded testimony
on thursday trump spent more than two
and a half hours in front of a
television in his private dining room as
rioters breached the capitol what people
were really asking president trump to do
including his own family and top
officials in the white house was for him
to put out a statement to the rioters to
stop and leave the capitol building
if the president had wanted to make a
statement
and address the american people he could
have been on camera almost instantly the
committee also played outtakes from a
video recorded at the white house on
january 7 2021 which showed that the
former president still refused to
concede that he lost the election this
election is now over
congress has certified the results i
don't want to say the election is over i
just want to say
congress has certified the results
without saying the election's over okay
it was the first time in history united
states that we did not have
a peaceful transfer of power
[Music]
cassidy hutchinson a one-time aide to
white house chief of staff mark meadows
testified in an earlier hearing that
trump knew that his supporters were
armed when he urged them to march to the
capitol
hutchinson said trump is briefed about
the presence of weapons at the rally but
was concerned that magnetometers were
keeping supporters from attending
i overheard the president say something
to the effect of you know i don't even
care that they have weapons
they're not here to hurt me take the
effing bags away
despite knowing all this he stands
before them and says
go to the capitol
the committee played never-before-seen
footage of rioters breaching the
building as officers braced for the
assault
testimony from capitol police officer
caroline edwards described the attacks
as a war scene i saw friends with blood
all over their faces i was slipping in
people's blood
the goal of that was to really show to
the american public many of whom may not
have seen footage like this before how
violent it was steven ayers a former
trump supporter who pleaded guilty to
breaching the capital testified that he
initially had no intention of going
there on the sixth basically
you know the president
you know got everybody riled up
told everybody head on down
so we basically just following what he
said
video showed rioters reading a tweet
sent by trump that criticized then vice
president mike pence for refusing to
block the electoral college count my
our kids and our constitution
the committee detailed the potential
peril to pence who became a clear target
of the mob
[Applause]
the crowds surged and within one minute
of trump's tweet made it to one floor
below where pence was waiting off the
senate floor
vice president pence and his team
ultimately were led to a secure location
where they stayed for the next four and
a half hours
barely missing rioters a few feet away
the main point that the committee was
trying to make with this is how trump
has this power over his followers and
they do what he says and he knows that
according to videotaped depositions
trump is told repeatedly by top justice
department officials and members of his
inner circle that he hadn't won the 2020
election and that claims a voter fraud
were without merit i told him that it
was
it was
crazy stuff trump continued to spread
election fraud claims including ones
that election workers brought a suitcase
full of fake ballots into an atlanta
voting facility evidence of fraud is
overwhelming and again i'm going to ask
you to look up at that very very
powerful and very expensive screen
hidden cases of possible ballots are
rolled out from under a table four
people under a cloud of suspicion
gabriel sterling a top republican
georgia election official addressed the
claims and testimony to the committee
what it actually showed was fulton
county election workers engaging in
normal ballot processing testimony from
georgia's secretary of state brad
raffensberger detailed requests by trump
aimed at overturning the election
results look all i want to do is this i
just want to find
uh
11
780
votes which is one more that we have
because we won the state there were no
votes to find that was an accurate count
that had been certified ruby freeman who
was a georgia election worker also
testified about how she received threats
so severe that at one point she went
into hiding after trump accused her of
participating in voter fraud
there is nowhere i feel safe
nowhere
do you know how it feels to have
the president of the united states to
target you
the public hearings laid out the
committee's view of the attack on the
capitol as a watershed historical moment
for american democracy and a red alarm
for threats it could face in the future
what they're saying is that they
continue to hear from new witnesses we
don't know who these people are but
we're being told that there's enough to
merit further hearings members of the
january 6 committee have indicated they
believe trump broke the law when he
attempted to overturn the 2020
presidential election but they have no
power to initiate a criminal
investigation they can't make charges
that's not their role but it is the role
of the doj the justice department is
conducting its own parallel
investigation into the january 6 attack
we are seeing signs that the
investigation is widening and
potentially looking at individuals in
trump's inner circle although as of yet
we don't have any sign that the doj is
is looking at mr trump himself
[Music]